[Musique]
alors j'aimerais qu'on commence par
faire un petit jeu d'imagination j'ai
ramené un verre qui malgré les
apparences trompeuses n'est pas un verre
mais j'aimerais que vous imaginiez que
ce ver est bel et bien réel vous allez
vous concentrer dessus donner toute
votre concentration votre imagination
concentrer dessus imaginer que ces
belles un vrai vert que je tiens la
malaisie ça vient
comme ça je sais que c'est pas facile
c'est pour ça que j'ai ramené une paille
et en fait quand mais la paille dans le
vert on peut avoir l'impression que je
peux boire deux verres ça vous êtes un
petit peu je vais peut-être qu'on tape
tape complètement sceptiques
non mais j'ai l'impression messieurs
dames que vous avez quand même plus
d'imagination que vous le pensez parce
que dans cette enveloppe
il vient de se passer quelque chose
comme si il y avait votre imagination
qu'avait pris forme c'est un peu
difficile à sortir parce que ce qu'il ya
dedans c'est assez volumineux en fait il
ya comme un verre rempli de jus d'orange
qui sort de cette enveloppe est ce moi
qui vous applaudissent si je pouvais
merci à la vôtre surtout et ben moi je
suis content parce que vous n'avez pas
complètement perdu toute votre
imagination
jeudi perdu parce que vous souvenez
c'est quand on était petits qu'on avait
le plus d'imagination on a inventé des
histoires ont créé des personnages on se
déguisait en faisait le clown etc
d'ailleurs ça c'est moi quand j'étais
petit mais ce qui est marrant avec cette
photo en fait c'est que on l'a tous
chine parce qu'on était tous comme ça on
adorait se déguiser on adoré faire
l'imbécile etc
et en plus chez moi comme on n'avait pas
la télé bon on voulait pas c'était un
peu moins la télé mes parents me
disaient moi c'est notre télé donc ça
nous va très bien comme ça parce que je
racontais des histoires mouvement taudis
neigeux raconter des blagues etc
et j'ai continué à grandir en étant un
petit peu cet enfant est un jour alors
que j'allais enfin devenir sérieux j'ai
étudié l'économie à la sorbonne quand
même et bien là j'ai découvert la
meilleure excuse au monde pour coty de
m'amuser j'ai découvert la magie je
pouvais m'amuser moi je pouvais amuser
les autres et en plus je pouvais gagner
ma vie donc je savais très bien ce que
j'allais faire après mais plus je
faisais de la magie plus je voyais
quelque chose dans le regard de mon
public qu'on avait tous quand on était
enfant je voyais un regard simple sans
barrières et surtout émerveillé et c'est
là que j'ai compris quelque chose en
fait c'est qu'en fait on est tous des
grands enfants au fond de nous y ait pas
que moi dans l'histoire elle pas que moi
qui étais la télé aujourd'hui
on a un petit peu l'impression que c'est
incompatible avec les choses sérieuses
que la société valorise comme la
connaissance la logique le savoir alors
qu'en fait c'est pas du tout
incompatible on peut très bien être
sérieux et garder cet état d'esprit
d'enfant avec les qualités qui vont avec
on s'émerveille et où on était heureux
sans raison en questionner l'impossible
aussi et nous les magiciens c'est
précisément pour ces qualités là qu'on a
décidé de rester des grands enfants tout
ce qu on fait surtout surtout dans le
travail
alors évidemment et heureusement on
n'est pas les seuls à avoir compris ça
ya des entreprises qui ont mis en place
dans leurs locaux par exemple des salles
de jeu comme ils l'ont fait chez google
ça c'est très connu mais aussi des
environnements de travail qui stimulent
l'imagination et notre état d'esprit
d'enfant comme ils l'ont fait chez pixar
il ya des directeurs chez pixar qui
travaillent sur des bureaux qui sont
remplis de jouets pourquoi ils font ça
parce qu'ils savent que c'est vital en
fait c'est plus un bonus maintenant
c'est vital en a tous besoin de stimuler
notre imagination de garder cet état
d'esprit d'enfant et de s'amuser donc
messieurs dames je vous propose là
dessus qu'on s'amuse tous un petit peu
vous allez tous pensé à une carte pour
cette deuxième carte h jeux de cartes
plastiques 1 2 peak dame de coeur ce que
vous les avez 50 de choix pensez tous en
garde
et moi je vais essayer deux la destinée
de winne est déjà et de la dessiner sur
ce sur ce carnet dont vous avez tous une
carte en tête
ouais par exemple est-ce que vous pouvez
vous lever se plaît celui-là
avant je faisais pas influencer une
quelconque manière vous avez libre au
chaud dans notre carte auquel faisait
une carte en tête nous appeler comment
eva je vais laisser parler mon
imagination maccabi by dad
et mon esprit d'enfant et je vais
deviner votre carte
regardez moi
ok ok 1 ça dure trois quarts d'heure ce
temps mais à la fin c'est super
impressionnant
nous avait bluffés à la fin crave traict
tak tak et va vous avez votre carte en
tête pour la première fois je veux
retourner ce bloc notes et si mon esprit
d'enfant si mon imagination folle a
réussi à capter ce qu'ils avaient dans
votre cerveau alors la carte que je
viens de dessiner ici c'est grâce à
laquelle vous avez pensé si j'ai bon
vous essayez si j'aime aussi j'veux pas
bon pour rester debout d'accord un deux
trois coups penser à l'as de pique
non non c'est non
mais je n'ai pas fini mon dessin en fait
je pense à ça ressemble à un magicien
qui explose au milieu de tedx mais c'est
pas grave c'est parce que je n'ai pas
fini mon dessin vous allez voir comment
on se rattrape nous l'imaginons c'était
quoi le nom de votre carte 5 de caron ça
tombe bien parce que j'avais dessiné un
paquet de cartes et j'étais sûr que 5 de
caro était dans ce paquet de cartes
ah ça vous impressionne sasa précède
pour vous asseoir déjà c'est sympa si
vous aussi vous l'essayez partir votre
imagination et votre état d'esprit
d'enfant vous vous rendriez compte
éventuellement qu'à une carte qui peut
sortir de ce paquet de cartes 20010
quelle carte le 5 de 40
est ce que il ya bien une carte qui sort
le 5 des carreaux merci et eva chanceuse
vous ne partez pas les mains vides car
j'ai tac tac tac un petit cadeau pour
vous et sous un tonnerre
d'applaudissements
on peut applaudir très fort et voir qui
repart avec une petite soeur l'applaudît
très fort la venue très fort quand même
tenez 20 petit souvenir merci beaucoup
merci à vous n'êtes pas si mauvais en
fait souvent on me dit comment tu as
fait du comment tu as fait tu comment tu
fais ses illusions comme sucrés banon
les magiciens on peux pas vous dire
comment on fait mais ce qu'on peut vous
dire c'est que pour créer ce genre
d'illusions ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait
appel à une capacité qu'on avait tous
quand on était enfant et cette capacité
c'est de pouvoir tout remettre en
question
c'est pour ça que les enfants sont plus
créatifs parce qu'ils se donnent
l'autorisation à eux mêmes de
questionner ce qui est qualifié d'
évident ou d'un possible par les autres
ce que nous ont fait de montgeon main
berck et des enfants ou petits frères
petite soeur dans la salle de verdun
bien au convoi donc vous savez aussi
bien que moi que ces petites créatures à
elles sont le don de poser des questions
qui nous surprennent qui nous coupe
l'herbe sous le pied et surtout surtout
qu'ils nous font réfléchir c'est parfois
qui nous énerve un petit peu mais c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont plus créatifs et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut s'en inspirer
et c'est pour ça que nous
magicien on a décidé de continuer à
faire ça questionnaire impossible pour
créer des illusions pour vous faire
rêver
alors certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être me dire ouais mais bout de six
mois je fais pas un magicien qu'est-ce
que je peux faire et si quand vous
accompagnez votre petit frère votre
fille au parc vous aussi vous faisait un
peu de beurre en soir pour voir comme ça
juste pour voir ce que vous ressentez et
si quand vous devez organiser un
brainstorming au boulot vous demandez à
vos collègues de venir déguisé comme si
c'était halloween
ouais en fait plus amusant non s'amusant
c'est facile c'est gratuit et en plus ça
peut vous permettre de changer de vision
sur votre monde parce que c'est ça la
clé au final on n'a pas besoin d'être
magicien pour le faire le but c'est de
pouvoir changer de perspective sur votre
quotidien pour voir votre monde à
nouveau avec des yeux d'enfants et ce
qui m'a beaucoup aidé moi dans ce
processus c'est de comprendre qu'en fait
bas ont été déjà tous entourés de magie
on la voit plus cette magie pour nous
c'est devenu banal de voir un avion qui
décolle un coucher de soleil
or pour un enfant ça reste
extraordinaire il voit cette magie voit
cette beauté d'ailleurs j'adore ce
concept qui dit la beauté est partout
mais tout le monde ne peut pas la voir
parce que les enfants eux la voie mais
vous savez quoi
si les enfants peuvent la voir si nous
pouvions l'avoir quand on était enfant
alors il est pas trop tard
on peut encore le faire mais ce qu'il
faut c'est porter un regard nouveau sur
ce qu'on a déjà et se rendre compte que
tout peut être source de magie
d'ailleurs à ce propos j'ai un petit
quelque chose à vous montrer
m
[Musique]
oh
mais
et
[Musique]
non
on
mais ce devrait tous nous amusons
pendant ce genre de magicien
rien d'autre je rêvais de faire ça mais
ça marche pas à tous les coups il ya
quelques années je terminerai cette
conférence sur sa g j'ai étudié en tant
que comédien il ya une phrase de
stanislavski qui m'a énormément touché
marqué profondément
il disait il faut étudier les enfants
car ils sont plus proches de la nature
pour ceux qui ne savent pas stanislavski
c'est le grand professeur de tad qui a
révolutionné le jeu d'acteur du 20e
siècle et cette phrase suis pas trop
compris au début je me suis dit ok mais
plus j'y réfléchis plus j'ai compris ce
qu'il voulait me dire ce qui devrait
nous dire c'est que si on voulait être
plus créatif
si vous voulez être plus serein si on va
être plus optimiste ou si on veut être
plus heureux tout simplement
alors on est train on allait forcément
être amené à réapprendre des qualités
qu'on avait déjà quand on était enfant
parce qu'on était plus proche de notre
état naturel et que ses qualités dont on
a parlé dans toute la conférence est
font partie de la nature humaine est
font partie de notre vraie nature c'est
d'ailleurs cette photo j'adore parce que
cet enfant c'est en poster vous cette
enfance et c'était moi et cet enfant ça
peut encore l'être
vos moi donc je vous laisserai sur une
petite confession est un souhait la
confession c'est que mon vrai nom c'est
pas bout de six état de choc par salle
mon vrai nom c'est johannes mes beauty
dans le dialecte allemand de ma mère ça
veut dire petit bout de chou petit
garçon et c'est comme ça que
traditionnellement on appelle le petit
dernier de la famille ce qui était le
cas pour moi pendant longtemps mais ce
surnom j'ai décidé de le garder exprès
en grandissant en tant que magicien en
tant que conférencier pour garder l'état
d'esprit qui va avec
pour moi et pour pouvoir le transmettre
aux autres donc si j'ai un souhait c'est
mon plus grand soin et je vous laisserai
avec ça aujourd'hui c'est que vous
puissiez retrouver votre âme d'enfant
pour faire ressurgir les miracles de
votre quotidien
merci beaucoup de votre attention
maintenant c'est à vous de jouer merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]